in the beginning i was being ignored
completely when they couldn't ignore me
i think i was the most cartooned the
most lampooned person on comedy shows
it was as if i was like the sort of
patron saint of lost causes
and then and then the moment that it
really changed
was in 2004 eight and then ten former
communist countries joined the european
union
with total rights of free movement and
this led to
millions of people coming into the
united kingdom it was too much
too quickly it was out of control and
that was the moment when i linked
the immigration issue with the
sovereignty issue the independence issue
and that was the moment that the
establishment turned on me
and they spent basically the next 15
years
trying to tell anyone that would listen
that i was a racist
leading a dark dangerous movement that
hark back
to the 1930s i mean nothing could have
been david nothing
could have been further from the truth
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
british activist
commentator former leader of the uk
independence party
as well as the former leader of the
brexit party
and now he's on tour right here in the
us of a
nigel farage i don't know how we haven't
done this before finally welcome to the
reuben report
i'm delighted to be here and uh yeah
i've
i've come actually with a very
optimistic message
because i know a lot of conservatives
here are really down at the moment you
know
down that their guy got 75 million votes
and somehow didn't win
down about what's going on in our cities
with
you know a deliberate attempt to divide
black and white people which is
horrendous
and down about what biden might do is he
gonna pack the court or that i mean
all these things and my sense from my
american friends
is some of them are down to the point of
being disillusioned yeah
and disillusioned movements pessimistic
movements
don't win so the message i've come with
is this
we voted brexit june 23 2016 a great
historic night
three years later guess what our
contract
our contract to leave on march 29th 2019
we woke up on march 30th not 88 not only
have we not left
it looked like there was no prospect of
us leaving and yet
we led a grassroots rebellion fight back
we've smashed the establishment we've
won we've got brexit
the socialist party in the uk who were
heavily on the remain side
and heavily pro-open borders are
literally being
crushed electorally week by week and my
message is
however bad it looks actually this
administration are making some terrible
mistakes
what is happening on the border
effectively turns every state
into a border state so my message is
don't be down don't get don't be mad
there's a big chance here
for a massive victory in 2022 and an
even bigger one
in 2024 but the right in america he
needs to unite
needs to have some common messaging just
one or two less egos
around the place might be quite helpful
but don't
look if we if we could beat the global
establishment
and get brexit back over the line you
can do it so i love the message
obviously there's something kind of
funny you're coming to america to bring
less ego that's uh
that that's that's a tough one that's a
tough one but
but you're one of the things that i love
about you and we've gotten to know each
other over the years a little bit we've
had a couple of gin and tonics together
once or twice but you're the type of
politician that actually
does instead of just talks can you talk
a little bit about what that is like
because
i think most people see politicians at
this point basically just
as bureaucrats who pretty much just take
their money and do nothing or maybe lock
them in their homes
but you actually make things happen and
that's got to be very different
than most of the people that you're
around often or have been around over
the years
so in june 99
um against the flow totally unpredicted
i found myself being elected as a member
of the european parliament
and everybody was shocked yeah who is
this guy what's this new party
and i remember the next morning the
phone rang and it was a guy who'd been a
commentator and a satirist in britain a
guy called christopher booker
very intelligent man and christopher
said to me that morning
he said nigel after 40 years of study i
can tell you
there are two types of people in
politics there are those
who want to be someone and there are
those who want to do something
and make your mind up young man i was
young then he said make your mind up
young man which of those you want to be
and here's the point he was absolutely
right the vast majority of people in
politics are there
for rank title position status
and they'll do i mean they'll sell their
grandmothers
to to climb the greasy pole because for
them it's all about career advancement
then you get people in politics who are
doing it out of genuine conviction
because they believe
the agenda they're pursuing is going to
make their country better and the lives
of their people better
and i personally couldn't give a damn
about titles people say oh you know
you're not lord nigel you're not sir
nigel i couldn't care less
about any of that i did this because i
could see
globalism building back in the 1990s
i could see bureaucracy was beginning to
win over democracy
and i was determined to do something
about it so yeah i'm a doer
uh i i you know i'm not here do you
remember when you first saw it when when
was the first moment that you saw
something that really alarmed you
the first big moment was in 1990
when the government pegged sterling
against the basket of european
currencies effectively the deutsche mark
now you know anybody with any economic
history knows all peg currency systems
end in disaster none of them through
through time ever succeed
and they've done it because they wanted
us to join what became the euro
and that was the first alarm bell that
whatever they were telling the
electorate come general election time
actually they were literally selling off
our country
uh and then there was a rebellion in
there was a rebellion back bench
conservatives rebelled
um over a new european treaty the treaty
that turned it
from an european community into a
european union with a flag an anthem and
all those things
and i watched this rebellion and right
at the last minute john major who was
the prime minister
used a motion of confidence to get this
treaty
pushed through and i couldn't believe it
but hang on
you've been telling me guys that if this
treaty goes through
we lose our independence and yet when it
came to it
you decided to put your career you
decided to put your party
above the interests of the country and i
realized then
that the so-called tory euroskeptics
were frankly
a bunch of chinless wonders a bunch of
losers
none of them have a stomach for the
fight and i said in 93
i'm going to do this i don't care if
people laugh at me
i don't care if i'm the only person that
votes for me i'm going to fight this and
do this
as a matter of principle and you know
frankly
uh that that that moment that spelled
the next 27 years of my life
did you have any idea the opposition
that you were going to come against i
mean when i was in london last time
when i saw you was during the the tour
with jordan peterson and it was in the
middle of brexit but there was still a
huge feeling like
ah maybe it's not gonna happen and maybe
the bureaucrats
still will take over or do some
last-minute tricks and then of course it
was framed
that all the people that supported it
were racists and bigots and all the rest
of it
but just the endless machine that we now
all see that has been so
exposed and in many ways from an
american perspective thanks to donald
trump
was so exposed did you realize how crazy
that machine was gonna
be and what it was gonna do to you and
your supporters
gandhi of course fought the campaign for
india to leave the british empire
and to get his independence and gandhi
once said first they ignore you
then they laugh at you then they attack
you and then you win and i went through
every one of those four stages you know
in the beginning i was being ignored
completely when they couldn't ignore me
i think i was the most cartooned the
most lampooned person on comedy shows
it was as if i was like the sort of
patron saint of lost causes
and then and then the moment that it
really changed
was in 2004 eight and then ten former
communist countries joined the european
union
with total rights of free movement and
this led to
millions of people coming into the
united kingdom it was too much
too quickly it was out of control and
that was the moment when i linked
the immigration issue with the
sovereignty issue the independence issue
and that was the moment that the
establishment turned on me
and they spent basically the next 15
years
trying to tell anyone that would listen
that i was a racist
leading a dark dangerous movement that
hark back
to the 1930s i mean nothing could have
been david nothing
could have been further from the truth
that is what they
tried to do and i have to tell you in
all honesty
you know if i'd known just how horrible
my life was going to be
i don't know whether i would have done
it i mean you know i finished having to
live
with protection around the clock uh if
you went out somewhere people threw
things at you
and this was the media this was
mainstream media working with big global
corporations
uh trying to maintain their own
self-interest
but in the end in the end you know you
can keep
putting out pushing accusations against
somebody but if you can't prove it
it's a little bit it's a little bit like
crying wolf and in the end people saw
through it but yeah
it was it was tough it was hard and then
you know i was perhaps guilty of some
naivety because on the 23rd of june
2016 that moment where we've won
and all the parties promised that they
would honor the result and then we saw
a three-year campaign as you say we were
told
we didn't know what we voted for we were
property prices would collapse we were
told millions of jobs would be lost we
were told
foreign direct investment from america
and elsewhere would dry up
we were even told brace yourself for
this one
we even told there would be an outbreak
of super
gonorrhea in the country because the
drug that was used to treat it
came from germany and we wouldn't even
get some you know supplies of drugs i
mean
there is no there is no depth to which
these people
did not sink but the resolve of the
british people
did not budge one inch and i believe
there is a parallel i don't believe
those 75 million people
who voted for donald trump have changed
their mind in fact i think in many ways
probably in their hearts they you know
they feel it
even more strongly and and that's why
i'm on this tour to spread that message
a message of optimism a message that you
can beat the odds you really can
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell